Mày hai người bày thằng sau năm 2018, kể giác thế là đã bắt sửa một người đàn ông
cuốc tịch Quốc tại Sinh Baiku Tee su văn nào buì. Thủ đô văn có,
xói lưng qua đến vụ giết người tại Patea, nạn nhân là cuộc gái người bày tuổi.
Thì thế được tìm thấy trong một chức phal y tại Patea và cuộc này.
Nghi phạm được xói lệ là xí mong Peter Caman, đối mặt với các cá mục,
giết người, giấu thế thế, giết trên hoặc tư vị thì thế và bắt cáp sẽ bị thành linh biệt mục đức sấu.
Chứ đó, các người ra anh nhưng cho thấy, các man bằng một cân hộ chung cư của mối câu gái vài dự sau,
các man dự đi một mình mang theo một chức phal y, người này chở trước phal y trên sẽ mấy và chạy đến một khu bực như có gần đường dây xe lưu.
Cảy sát sau đó đã phát lựng mất sửa và đã bắt được các man tại Sinh Baiku,
anh ta đang trường vị lên mấy bài chờ vị uc.
Hình cạnh sát chờ cho biết khi nào các man sẽ hổ thóa.